[Musique]
lles yes yes yes
bonjour à tous si on doit faire un homme
boxing d'un smartphone que j'attendais
depuis quelques temps j'avais vraiment
hâte de pouvoir prendre en main pour
aller tester tout voir voir avec vous
s'il est bien oui ou non il est là on y
va maintenant
bon vous avez vu titre de la vidéo je
vais pas vous mentir forcément vous
n'êtes pas arriver là non plus par
hasard ce smartphone c'est le tout
nouveau smartphone de samsung qui m'a
été envoyé par mon partenaire ya phone
point com merci beaucoup ya phone
démarre en fait parvenir ce smartphone
que je peux tester grâce à vous alors
justement ce smartphone je trouve assez
intéressant parce que samsung
effectivement vous connaissez la marque
je peux vous faire un historique vous
connaissez parfaitement et parker
samsung sort beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de nouveaux produits très intéressants
et là on a eu en ce début d'année le à 8
à 8 plus le l8 vous avez pu la voir dans
l'hexagone
dans d'autres pays comme la belgique on
a pu avoir lieu à 8 plus mais en france
non le samsung galaxy s mais après ce
n'est plus mon été commercialisés qui
fonctionne priori plutôt pas mal pas
autant que samsung pourrait l'espérer
mais bon fonctionne quand même plutôt
pas mal et puis là on a le samsung
galaxy à 6 alors celle-ci se situe très
post c'est dur à dire ça soit six se
situent que très clairement si le lire
je parte ceci se fait cette fois ci se
situe très clairement dans le milieu de
gamme
néanmoins est ce qu'il est intéressant
est ce qu'il faut l'acheter par rapport
au galaxy à 8
c'est un peu la question qu'on va
essayer de se poser dans cette première
vidéo à faire un autre boxing va nourrir
on va regarder ce qu'elles ont la boîte
on va le prendre en main et puis je vous
donnais mes premières impressions par
rapport à ce produit quand vous voyez
ces morceaux voire il est tout frais il
est tout neuf dont je ne connais pas
encore
j'ai pu le voir en photo comme
probablement beaucoup d'entre vous mais
là pour le coup on va voir effectivement
ce que ça dit une fois qu'on touche la
dette dans une prochaine vidéo à faire
un test
on va effectivement pouvoir voir s'il
est cool plus en détail les photos la
vidéo le comparer au à huit gardes et un
petit peu par rapport à ses concurrents
principaux par rapport au nord 10 par
rapport à plein d'autres produits un
petit peu je dirais sensiblement
équivalent qui sensiblement je prend des
pincettes parce qu'effectivement ce
n'est pas le ordis pas le même produit
on va pas le comparer non plus
exactement adobe à d'autres produits
mais voilà on peut en tout cas quand on
a un certain budget se poser la question
est-ce que je vais vers ce produit est
ce que je vais vers cet autre produit
c'est peu dans ce sens là que je
l'entends donc dans une prochaine vidéo
valve était sinon je vous invite à vous
abonner dès maintenant car on va
regarder ça et puis il ya plein de tests
qui vont arriver un jeu des produits à
tester j'ai vu le monde connecté g
différences parfois il ya le week au vu
de pro tu veux sortir le test très très
prochainement
j'ai d'autres smartphones intéressante
et c'est pas mal de choses à voir donc
dès maintenant abonnez vous allez voir
on va pouvoir avancer un petit peu et
faire différents comparatifs voir ce qui
est intéressant
il n'y a pas et compagnie donc on reste
connectés les amis et maintenant vital
bcd jolie pousse des like et puis on y
va tout de suite pour le unboxing de ce
samsung galaxy à 6 le voilà bon son
emballage de lumière fournie par iphone
alors je vais essayer de voir quel sens
était fermée ce truc allez hop voit un
petit peu à quoi il ressemble voilà
boîtes à 6 review monsieur voleurs
savent bien évidemment vous ne l'aurez
pas sur votre bonne je vous rassure tout
de suite ça n'apparaitra pas c'est donc
le samsung galaxy sii salon a
effectivement une boîte je dirais
relativement simple package blanc comme
on avait sur le a8
qu'est ce qu'on va voir sur le côté bon
vas pas grand chose européenne si mme
cardonne lit ça tombe bien c'était le
but
c'est le modèle noir le numéro de série
on voit effectivement qu'on a un écran
super amoled un cran un fils qui
fullmetal un processeur 64 bits oct
accord une caméra avant de 16 mégapixels
une caméra arrière de 16 mégapixels 32
gigas de stockage et 3 giga de ram
allez on y va on ouvre un petit peu ça
on va essayer de voir attention par un
patin jolivettes plutôt bien présentés
alors effectivement il ya d'autres
d'autres packaging j'ai pu trouver
beaucoup plus sexy beaucoup plus joli à
ouvrir mais bon malgré tout j'aime bien
les smartphones de samsung alors ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va arriver
d'ici quelques instants ce smartphone on
va le découvrir ensemble on va gagner
d'abord c'est un peu le contenu de la
boîte voir ce qu'il peut y avoir là
dedans car h et comme d'habitude
qu'est ce qu'il ya ça c'est quoi là
c'est le certificat de garantie
régionale le niveau qui bon ça c'est
parfait ça je ne sais pas je ne parle
pas cette langue
voilà donc très sympathique ok merci
samsung
on retrouve ici un cas micro usb esata
usb type c mais bon c'est comme ça avec
de l'usb on a ici hop
l'autre partie pour charger on a une
paire d'écouteurs fort sympathique ma
foi puis c'est déjà pas mal je pense que
là on a fait un petit peu le tour de la
question va maintenant passer aux
smartphones en lui-même alors on va
retirer cette jolie partie attention
c'est ici que tout se joue
je trouve pas hyper hyper léger première
prise en main c'est assez marrant alors
je l'avais avec le papier vous le dirai
le poids tu l'avais directement d'accord
mais là ça qu'une fois comme ça je j'ai
l'impression de me rends compte pas
forcément en prise en main par rapport
au format ça fonctionne
j'ai pas des mains énorme j'ai pas des
mains de bûcheron donc moi j'ai vraiment
la main de monsieur et madame tout le
monde alors que monsieur tout le monde
que madame tout le monde
je trouve que le lecteur d'empreintes
digitales on trouve assez bien alors
pareil toujours le même reproche même si
effectivement samsung a corrigé et n'a
pas laissé son antre son lecteur
d'empreintes digitales
à côté néanmoins quand on cherche on a
toujours flirté un petit peu ici avec
l'appareil photo donc en termes de
traces de doigts je continue à penser
que c'est pas idéal
il le faudrait un peu plus bas ou alors
pourquoi pas mettre l'appareil photo sur
le côté ce qui laisserait vraiment le
champ libre directement au capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous avez une
belle façade avant ici votre caméra vous
avez un flash vous avez les différents
capteurs et s'il est là en bas on voit
qu'on a une bande noire quand même assez
importante sur le bas et également sur
le haut de notre côté on n'est pas sur
les smartphones haut de gamme
bon on pouvait s'y attendre c'est là où
on voit effectivement tout le choix
intéressant café oic haut avec son vieux
de prod se dire là je vous mets une
petite encoche comme ça je peux profiter
un peu plus de mon écran j'ai
effectivement une bande noire en bas je
vais pas l'éliminer mais par contre rien
à gagner un petit peu de place sur le
haut peut pas tout avoir non plus
d'autant plus que samsung a vraiment
fait ce choix pour l'instant ne pas de
mettre d'encoches de résister que
proposait des grands écrans sur le côté
on a ici le bouton pour l'allumer potins
ici je ne sais pas ce que c'est que
cette partie là je vais me poser la
question je vais je vais me regarder un
petit peu ce que c'est que ça on dirait
que ça haut parleur il ya une petite vie
ça fait un petit peu haut parleurs parce
que ce que vous vous en pensez marqué le
mans commentaire donc il sait le bouton
on off
vous avez ici le bouton de volume ici la
partie pour insérer votre carte nano est
là une plus grande partie c'est
probablement pour ajouter de la mémoire
à nouveau versé ensemble
vous avez ensuite sur le dessus
absolument rien on a 17 ans a rien qui
est particulièrement magnifique on va
pas se mentir et vous avez en dessous
votre emplacement ici pour le recharger
avec du micro usb ça c'est bizarre mais
pas d'usb tic c'est le probablement pour
une question de coût est ici un port
jack ou à vous on a gardé un port jack
alors on va regarder pour prouver un
petit peu ce qu'ils voient ce qu'il ya
un peu de ce côté là vient par là mon
petit s'il te plaît rentre et vient ne
me fais plus attendre qu là très
clairement
vous voyez vous avez uniquement une
seule partie pour votre carte sim c'est
noté ici assez intéressant ici vous
et de la micro sd et ici sur le côté
peut-être une deuxième carte sim ça
pourrait être intéressant effectivement
ici la première carte sim ici je pense
la deuxième carte sim dans le deuxième
une petite irois est ici l'emplacement
pour votre carte microsd alors
maintenant on va l'allumer premières
vibrations formidable samsung galaxy à 6
au cas où on l'aurait pas compris ça met
un peu de temps à s'ouvrir là j'attends
j'attends j'attends le temps le temps
s'écoule tranquillement j'attends bon il
faut un petit peu de patience des fois
il faut pas il était pas un français ce
qui va falloir aulas comme en espagne la
casse avait bien dit oh oui bienne
initièrent d'accord est-ce qu'on peut
éventuellement changer et passer en
français de france ça me conviendrait
ils vous remercient démarrage à les ans
un petit démarrage à une carte sim pour
accéder au réseau
on verra tout ça un peu un peu plus tard
pour l'instant on a eu d'accord avec
tout on accepte du tout de toute façon
j'ai clairement pas trop le choix
on va l'appeler concours je pense que
vous en pensez mon nom c'est coucou
configurer la reconnaissance faciale le
scanner d'iris toute la configuration je
la ferai ultérieurement la voilà je
voulais vraiment le prendre en main voir
un petit peu la prise en main moi je le
trouve bien voilà il tient bien dans la
main
sympathique plutôt pas mal on peut le
faire tourner je vais éviter de trop le
faire tourner trop le faire jeter parce
que bien évidemment ce n'est pas mon
smartphone en termes de prise en main ça
va je vous dis bon moi ce que je
regrette vraiment c'est toujours cet
aspect là pour venir déverrouiller parce
que si vous voulez vraiment positionner
votre doigt au milieu en termes
d'empreinte digitale vous allez
forcément flirté avec la caméra du coc
falloir la nettoyer du coup ça va être
pénible
voilà le l'accès aux touches est très
facile ici le bouton de volume se trouve
très très facilement avec votre majeur
avec votre pouce vous avez ici accès
très facilement aussi ici pourquoi pas
effectivement je confirme ici en ce sens
les haut parleurs bien évidemment il y
en a absolument pas en bas donc c'est
une idée pour valeo par ailleurs c'est
plutôt le haut parleur c'est du beau
parleur mono
donc voila un petit peu je trouve ça
plutôt pas mal fichu voilà pour le hand
boxing de ce samsung galaxy à 6 d'ici
quelques jours
comme je vous disais quelques instants
on va faire un test complet laissez moi
le temps un peu de le prendre en main de
de voir comment il est si les biens
non je peux pas le faire comme ça parce
que si je vous fais un test dans la
foulée comme ça paraît toute mobilité
alors on va faire un test tranquillement
le temps de bien laisser bien tester de
faire un tour complet de regarder un
petit peu par rapport aux autres
produits que j'ai pu prendre en main
tester et par rapport à d'autres
produits que j'ai pas pu prendre en main
avoir un petit peu lequel est
intéressant lequel est plus ou moins
intéressants donc ça je vous le faire
mais ces quelques jours donc rester
connecté bien évidemment comme d'hab
deux jours merci d'être présent toujours
plus nombreux toujours plus nombreuse
directement sur la chaîne
enfin c'est super cool ça fait
extrêmement plaisir merci à tous du fond
du coeur il serait peut-être que tu
allais vous êtes con samsung galaxy sii
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on en parle
depuis quelques jours d'ici là je vous
embrasse
prenez soin de vous soyez sages et à
bientôt ciao
[Musique]